le Cadre Noir de Saumur a une longue
histoire et une tradition remarquable le
maintien et la diffusion de ces
pratiques contribue à promouvoir des
valeurs sociétales importantes sont
l'ouverture au grand public grâce à des
gala permet au cadre noir de rayonner à
travers le monde en France et à
l'étranger c'est une véritable perle
culturelle et sociale Laurence et
Frédéric vont m'expliquer pourquoi
je vais aller par là du coup
[Musique]
c'est la voix off de la matinale c'est
ça c'est exactement ça oui donc tout est
prêt et tout alors je vais essayer
effectivement de faire comprendre public
qui n'est pas connaisseur ce qui se
passe avec les chevaux on te laisse te
concentrer et mais merci pour ton côté
DJ j'apprécie énormément la musique
baroque
ce matin illustre la collaboration qui
existe entre les écuries et leurs
chevilles dans différentes disciplines
le cheval va sauter au dessus de la
table c'est passé easy au cadre noir
aura déjà son trou
Camille hypnose de chevaux je vais
attirer les chevaux vers nous
[Musique]
Frédéric
super voix off je comprenais tout ce que
t'expliquer les figures le pourquoi du
comment c'était génial alors
explique-moi la différence entre le
cadre noir et l'Institut tradition de
d'équitation française je l'ai mal dit
français du cheval et de l'équitation
comment ça fonctionne alors le cadre
noir lui a 200 ans d'histoire et
l'Institut lui est un établissement
public qui est né en 2010 le cadre noir
a fusionné avec les Haras nationaux pour
créer l'Institut français du chef
d'équitation le cadre noir lui est donc
une composante de l'institut qui a des
missions très larges pour la filière
équine en général et le cadre noir lui a
pour objectif de faire de la formation
et de transmettre au grand public les
savoirs de l'équitation française
immatériel de l'Unesco en 2011 c'est
l'équitation de tradition française donc
une façon de monter à cheval et le cadre
noir lui a été officiellement reconnu
par l'UNESCO comme étant le représentant
le plus emblématique pour représenter ce
patrimoine
aussi au patrimoine immatériel parce
qu'elle est extraordinaire je suis fan
on se quitte en musique baroque
[Musique]
je fais ce que je peux Laurence tu es
donc écuyer on n'est pas au féminin pour
l'instant peut-être ça va changer
peut-être qu'est-ce que l'écuyer déjà
ici au cadre noir c'est avant toi un
expert en équitation dans une des trois
disciplines olympiques ils sont soit
écrit de dressage de concours complet ou
de saut d'obstacles mais également et ça
c'est très important c'est un formateur
d'excellence de chevaux et d'hommes
c'est combien de représentations par an
sur le site ici on a quatre grands galas
et ensuite on a deux trois ou quatre
déplacements en plus de cela on a les
présentations qu'on appelle matinales
comme ce matin qu'on va être là vraiment
pour expliquer au public comment on
forme les chevaux qu'est-ce que
l'équitation tradition française on va
bientôt fêter le bicentenaire donc on
espère que ce sera aussi un bon tremplin
pour voilà bien faire connaître cette
institution
en 2025 rendez-vous en 2025 ici au cadre
noir avec Kamini en roue libre sur
France 3 centre Val de Loire merci
Laurence à très bientôt